tu connais l'histoire de marc côtoient
et le roi de l'arnaqué c'est le roi de
l'arnaqué qui s'est fait choper ouais
j'ai voulu me faire chopper parce que
j'ai regretté un petit peu ouais bah il
a ils haïssent été chopé il a payé le
prix gp aux arnaques par exemple un jour
j'aimerais bien savoir ce que tu peux
nous raconter marco n'aura que des
sérénades savoir et beaucoup ont
l'impression que l'ex-idole et non
attends on est le palais c'est pas toi
et on garde ça en tête la reine de l'arn
est le roi des nains bbd se parler à mes
gosses sur l'année leur voyage riche je
monte pas d' arnaque le jeu moi je suis
un affairiste ça veut dire que c'est moi
après les autres sinon je travaille je
monte une structure je travaille je
travaille et dès que je ne peux plus
m'en sortir jarnac jarlett pas je pense
que j'ai à prendre
survie ya peu pape et saturne est passé
à 300 bars
à beyrouth et
les sécher ne peut pas savoir moi je
vole pas les gens voient la haye volet
moi je vole pas eh ben c'est à votre
honneur à d'accord s'il te plaît on fera
émergents mais
tu veux te laissera parler tu me demande
de répondre oui si une fois j'avais
j'avais 150 magasins de détail et un
jour je me lève un matin tout allait
bien pour moi j'ai une descente inopinée
une vraie descente inopinée des impôts
et nous avons vraiment inopinée à
s'appelle inopinés chaleur rejetée en
robe de chambre à la maison qui fait de
nous un seul combat me rentrent en 40 et
ils bloquent tous les magasins et ils me
disent monsieur mouly on vous contrôle
immédiat et mon contrôler mes costumes
mais je te parle de sa gamme et vincent
pascal viable et laisse moi de parler il
y avait des fraudes ils viennent pas
pour faire ma parole d'homme que n'en
arrête actrice il sera content qu'il
soit tombé juste sur noisy inopinément
non ils sont pas tombés pour rien son
maire sont pas privés pour rien mais la
différence c'est que le jour ils vont
fermer tous mes magasins et toute ma
structure a été il va falloir qu'ils me
remboursent donc je me suis fait
rembourser c'est tout je comprends je
comprends non non non non non non ça non
mais je comprends il n'a pas volé qu'il
a travaillé dur
que non mais en fait il a voulu il avant
lui tu la voulais pas la route il a
évolué il a voulu sauver son cul comme
on dit dans marco en tout cas l'histoire
c'est qu'il a payé il a payé il a fait
mais c'est ça le très serré et j'ai payé
réellement ça veut dire que normalement
quand il prend huit ans tu fais quatre
mois j'en ai fait sept 7 ans à chaque
année devant la devant le jeu devrait à
la présidente la jugeant bien on peut
vous laisser sortir vous croyez à me
disais je dis oui bien sûr on peut me
laisser sortir là c'est bon ça y est
c'est que de l'argent et d'un seul coup
nous procure
c'est moi qui dit je veux pas sortir
n'avez vous pas sentir tellement moi on
m'a fait vraiment payant mais c'est vrai
qu'il a fait nommer mais elle parlait
dans les lâche tout à l'heure et là il a
purgé sa peine dans l'essentiel est là
ce soir demandé ce que j'en pensais je
pense que quelqu'un qui a purgé sa peine
y ait plus de débat exactement il ya
purge accord m points et en plus de ça
j'ai purgé ma peine mais ils m'ont mis
des autres affaires ça veut dire qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ya une escroquerie
maintenant c'est marco mouly ah ouais
bon tu poster sous peu
à
chaque fois la jeune aide mis en examen
pour une affaire béghin say je comprends
rien oui mais ça c'est le problème c'est
qu'à 70 millions de passionnés la mode
de béganne sais pas ce que je t'ai
ghinea desquels c'est moi qui les a pris
c'est moi qui a pris les 70 millions
donc à chaque fois qu'elle en a chaque
fois qu à une arnaque capable dé vanessa
pas est-ce que tu es loin de cette
arnaque ou t'es pas trop loin
diarra vérité franchement et
j'ai bossé on m'a donné d'argent
j'ai travaillé comme tu travailles comme
tout le monde travaille comme les
avocats travaillent à bizarre j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas comme tout le
monde
l'a complètement tout à fait comme un
monde joie et on s'est dit ça se voit
que c'est un mec qui va au charbon et
moi je te respecte en tout cas la taille
est pas te fait envie qu'il est dans ta
chemise
attijari la
barre qu elle a eu tout bon sens et non
mais là et a eu un crush pour lui mais
pas du tout moi j'aime les j'aime les
gens parce qu'il a expliqué une chose
qui était fantastique pour moi quand je
lui ai parlé de rocquencourt il m'a dit
non moi j'ai jamais rien volé j'ai fait
les choses il ya eu des circonstances
avions moi j'aime les gens qui serait
beau matin que l'ambition jules qui font
des choses maintenant effectivement ci
s'est fait prendre et sans prendre pas à
pas comme ça mais si vous êtes c'est
bondé légale et que vous avez fait des
shows justement en vrai que vous ayez
défendre notre bifteck j'ai beaucoup
plus de compassion et je respecte les
gens qui se battent qui vont au charbon
alors oui tout le monde essaie de se
défendre et voilà que je respecte les
gens même chose